are you doing a 20-year so how has it
changed because we taught political
correctness in the way TV is so uptight
a lot of guys it's so hard to not so
many guys in the sports world because
sports guys talk a certain way get in
trouble for like a comment that will be
okay in the locker room that's not even
it's unreal and it's and I saw it from
my dad you know I talked about that a
little bit in the book you know my dad
made jokes or made light of situations
that if you did now if you did that now
you wouldn't last till the end of the
inning you they'd come in and like send
you to Guantanamo Bay ever saying some
of the stuff that he got away with and
it was just kind of laughed off now does
that make it right I'm not saying it's
right but the business has changed to
the point where when you're doing a game
for 40 million people in game 7 of a
world series and you want to be funny or
you want to be cute or you want to talk
about the super moon or whatever you
better be a right and be if you're funny
you better be boring funny right because
you're gonna piss a lot of people off in
today's world that just not 130 million
people listening at the same time no
matter what joke you make someone's
gonna be bothered well that's it people
are tuning in to you they know what
they're gonna get right and they they
like you know they like what you guys do
they're stuck with me doing the game and
they could be in a nursing home they
could be at a frat party but it's still
my voice and if you want to start going
into areas that are off the beaten path
you better be really careful but that's
part of it too i think in especially in
the last few years anyway is that maybe
the NFL more than baseball but baseball
too they're trying to open these sports
up to as many conceivable eyes as
possible so you're not just going out to
the typical football fan the typical
baseball fan they're trying to get
families they're trying to get all these
people doubt so you better make sure
that you line up with that yeah you're
always trying to get new people under
the tent watching this stuff and you
know that's to me it's also hurt the NFL
with these international games and
starting games at 8am and London and
people aren't seeing them and it's hurt
ratings I think that's one of the issues
everybody's talking why are the NFL
ratings down that's a part of it but
again it's made everybody boring it's
made everybody
right down the middle lane and every
announcer sounds like everybody else and
it's too bad because the real
personalities the harry caray's and guys
like that are long gone and and that
that act wouldn't work anymore